[Music]
hey you guys book review time once again
now here's another book that i came
across uh with my kindle unlimited
subscription and it was one again that
was just kind of randomly suggested to
me and i thought the cover looked cool
and the title sounded interesting and i
ended up reading uh something that was
quite awesome
by an author that i hadn't heard of
before even though he's written several
other books
now i will warn everybody this is an
extreme horror novel
it says so right on the cover
now it's not quite to the extent of the
book that i talked about a while back
cows which was probably one of the
grossest things i ever read
this book is gross
but
not to that degree but if you're not
into extreme horror then this is
probably going to be like too much for
you because it's pretty disgusting it's
not disgusting it's not like
over-the-top gore um and there's not
like a lot of because i kind of feel
like cows was gross to me because it was
like a lot of [ __ ] and vomit-based
things which really grosses me out like
way more than gore does this basically
only has kind of one brief like [ __ ]
adjacent kind of thing mostly it's
really extreme
like sexual kind of gross outs and body
horror type of stuff also like real
[ __ ] up like psychological
uh kind of things so it's more in that
kind of way but it is still very much
extreme so if you're not into that then
probably give it a pass but
um i will say that actually it's a
novella so it's not super super long but
i really really dug this there was just
something about the vibe of it that i
don't know just really kind of like got
to me
so this book is called womb and it was
written by a canadian writer named
duncan ralston now this book came out in
2021.
now as i said duncan ralston had written
a few novels previously and uh had
written some like short story
anthologies and stuff like that now
there were some notes at the end of this
particular book i read the e-book as i
mentioned
uh where he said that this was actually
even though he'd written kind of like
some shorter stories of you know quote
unquote extreme uh fiction before
this was kind of his first attempt at
like a long form uh extreme horror and
to be honest i think he hit it out of
the park like i said yes it's gross yes
it's disturbing yes there's some really
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happens in
this
but
i think i brought this up when i was
talking about uh the matthew stoko book
cows that there's a very very fine line
with extreme horror and it's like i've
read some of it i'm not like a big
connoisseur of it or anything
but sometimes i'm in the mood for it so
i've read some of the ones you know kind
of the big ones in the genre but there's
a fine line between just writing
something to just be disgusting or
shocking like for the sake of it like
look how [ __ ] up i am like look at
this [ __ ] up [ __ ] that i can like just
get you know what i mean and it's like
it doesn't really have anything to do
you know it's like it's not really in
service to the larger narrative or the
theme or anything like that this book
absolutely does not uh have that problem
and in fact
this might be one of the very very few
extreme horrors that i've read that
while it's disgusting and revolting and
all of that kind of stuff that you
expect in your extreme horror it's also
surprisingly
heartfelt uh it's actually quite
beautifully written uh the characters of
which there are really only two it's
kind of like a frame story i'll get into
that in a little bit
but
you kind of really do get to know these
characters the characters are very
layered and complex and you actually
like really feel for them like while
they kind of go on this journey together
and like kind of tell these like [ __ ]
up stories to one another and i think
that that is really
its strength i really got into these two
characters they're very they're both
very sympathetic even though like [ __ ]
up [ __ ] has happened to both of them
they both done [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
they just seemed very human and they
seemed very sympathetic that you know
what i mean and i kind of feel like the
interaction between them was really
you know and some of the stuff that
happened was like very heartbreaking
so
i think this is maybe one of the few
extreme wars that i've read that was
like that that wasn't just and i'm not
saying that all extreme horror is just
like all edge lordy like look how [ __ ]
up i can be but some of it does fall
into that camp i'll admit this one's
really not like that um it really does
have
a larger theme to it and the
characterization and this was just
really really excellent and i just
really really liked the whole i don't
know it was just kind of like a whole
vibe of it that i really enjoyed so he
said that he got the idea for writing
this
uh when he was watching the movie room
you know about the woman that has the
baby and she's like trapped by the
rapist and the basement room or whatever
it was
so he got the idea for it while he was
watching that and then he realized that
room and womb were kind of like a same
kind of thing and then it kind of like
sprung outward uh from there
now what happens is this book is
it's kind of like
i don't want to like sell this too much
but it's like it's kind of like an
anthology
in the sense that
the frame story is just like these two
main characters sort of like telling
each other stories
but the stories kind of all end up
interconnected like interlocking with
one another or you know they all like
are thematically similar or they all
have something to do with the like the
larger narrative
so in that way
it the book it most reminds me of was um
haunted by chuck palahniuk and uh indeed
the author of this book duncan ralston
has said that uh you know that's one of
his big influences and obviously um it's
this it was a big influence on this book
because it's structured similarly
now i will say this and this may be a
very very bold statement and i'm not
saying that haunted isn't a great
[ __ ] book because it is
i think i liked this one better
i think i like this one better because
while i loved haunted i kind of felt
like it was a little
sprawling it seemed a little more
like an anthology in the sense that the
you know the stories were maybe
thematically connected but they weren't
like all connected into one big hole
and there was a lot of different
characters and none of them were super
super likable
this story
uh womb is a lot more intimate because
really it's only focusing on two main
characters and all the stories i mean
it's mostly just like the one guys
stories but like you know the woman
tells a couple stories as well
and all the stories sort of like are
interconnected or all kind of part of
the same narrative so they're not even
though they seem like they're all over
the place like when they kind of like
mention what they're about it might seem
like it's just this random collection of
you know gross nauseating stories but
they all kind of like serve a common
purpose and like our feed into a larger
narrative so i don't know so there was
just something about the more intimate
setting of it the more
um you know the more tighter focus on
just two characters that were actually
really sympathetic and really likable
and just the way the stories all kind of
came into one whole they can you know
they can be read as their own stories
like standalone sort of but all together
they kind of like add up to something
greater you know what i mean and so in
that way i think i preferred the
experience of reading this to the
experience of reading haunted if that
makes any sense and like i said i'm not
saying the haunted isn't a brilliant
book because it is i'll have to review
that one of these days i actually did
read it but it was a while back i'll
have to do like a reread and
do it on this show because i feel like
that's one that everybody has to do it's
just kind of one that you have to
so here's the setup and like i said this
is another book that
all i knew about it as i said was you
know the title the cool kind of looking
cover which just has like this old motel
on it and the fact that it says an
extreme horror novel so i knew that i
was going to be getting into something
disgusting i didn't know what kind of
disgusting what flavor of discussing it
was going to be but that's kind of all i
knew about it i was like why the hell
not it was a novella and you know it was
short and i said well i could probably
just like read this in an afternoon
which actually i did because i was
really like uh compelled to finish it
because like i said i got really
emotionally invested i got really into
it
so i want to say though that that's
probably the best way to go into this is
not knowing anything about it like i
didn't because i think that's
i don't know i just think it's better to
go it's better to go most books like
that but some books doesn't matter as
much i think this one's kind of better
to go into not knowing so i'm trying i'm
not gonna spoil anything outright but i
am kind of gonna give a little bit of an
you know maybe
one sentence summation of like what some
of the stories are about
um just so if you're thinking about
reading it but you're like oh i don't
know if i could handle extreme horror or
something like that maybe if i kind of
give you
a hint of like what the stories are
about like that will decide you whether
you want to read it or not but like i
said i kind of feel like this is better
going into it not really knowing
anything about it like i did it because
it was just kind of like surprising and
like i said it was it was a happy
surprise and as i said this is
absolutely not something i would say
about most extreme horror most extreme
horror like you just kind of read it
want to read it because it's gross and
you just want to see like how how far
people can like transgress the
boundaries of good taste and [ __ ] like
that this has that in it too it's you
know it's not the grossest thing i've
ever read by a long stretch i mean it's
up there there's some pretty [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happens in this but
the fact that it has such a
such a human like beating heart in the
middle of it i think like was really
something new for me so i thought that
was really cool like i said i don't know
if he writes a lot of
extreme or otherwise i mean what i took
from
the notes that he wrote at the end of
the book where he was talking about
where he got the idea um and he seems
like i mean at least from the from the
notes at the end he seemed like a very
nice like self-effacing kind of dude
which i was kind of like but he was like
well he'd written some short extreme
horror before but from what i could
determine and from what i could you know
see from other people's reviews of some
of his other novels this isn't
usually like this is a lot more extreme
than he would usually write but because
his writing style was so immersive and i
really got into it um i will definitely
be checking out some of his other longer
works uh to see what you know what those
are like
so what we have is
our main protagonist is a young man
named angel now angel is
this kind of like he's very uh kind of
sharp dressed dude
uh bald guy and his face is like all
kind of scarred up um he makes kind of a
lot of
you know statements about being like
really ugly and all this other kind of
stuff
now at the beginning of the book he
arrives at this kind of no-tell motel
kind of place like out on the outskirts
of town one of those places that you can
like pay by the hour it's like really
skeezy and it's called the lonely motel
now he checks into
room number six
now you're led to believe that he has
come here for a purpose like he says at
the beginning that this is the room that
his mother died in
and so it seems as though he's come to
some point in his life where
he wants like some kind of not
necessarily closure but he wants some
kind of if this isn't too much of a
spoiler he wants some kind of reset
because his life has been so [ __ ] up
he kind of talks about he's kind of
maybe coming full circle and it's like
fitting that he's come back to this
place kind of where it all began this is
where my mom died in this room
so he comes to this room and he's kind
of talking a little bit about how he
doesn't really believe in like spirits
or like something being haunted but how
he kind of does believe that a place
where a lot of
people experience extreme pain can maybe
sort of
that can maybe sort of soak into the
walls and like when you come in there
you know you can kind of feel the
oppression of this all of the horrible
things that happened in this room
so
he comes in with a backpack like i said
he seems to have some kind of plan but
you don't really find out what it is
until like later on in the story and
like i said this is kind of like the
frame story uh and then it sort of goes
into him swapping stories with somebody
else
so
uh the first thing he does when he gets
there is he calls an escort service
and he orders
a sex worker he wants an escort and he
specifies he's like i want a plus-sized
woman and he's like just the bigger the
better you know what i mean he's like
last time i called because apparently
he's tried to do this before whatever it
is that he's trying to do
um he's like last time i called like the
woman that you sent over she wasn't
right you know she wasn't big enough and
um you know so we need to like sort that
out
so a little while later uh the sex
worker shows up and her name is shyla
and apparently uh she's just what he
wanted um you know she's very very uh
large she's a very large woman and uh
she's also delightful she has like a
delightful delightful personality she's
kind of sardonic and it's just like i
don't know i just like i said i really
really liked both of these characters
and i liked like the interaction with
each other
so
so she kind of comes in
and
it seems that you know you would think
he hired a sex worker it's like you know
for obvious reasons but it seems that at
first all he wants to do is talk and
she's just kind of like okay whatever
it's your money you know
like you would so he starts to tell her
a story
and the story that he tells her and like
i said this is kind of like an anthology
but all the stories kind of like
interconnect
in uh ways that you discover later on
so he tells this story about a guy named
johnny and he had a girlfriend named
jenny and how he would do anything for
that girl and it was this whole thing
and he kind of talks a little bit about
their relationship and everything and uh
this relationship goes in
really really horrible ways and all i'll
say about it um and this is the one that
has a little bit of the [ __ ] adjacent
stuff in it so it's just kind of like oh
man it's like cows all over again but
like poop poop for days but this is
really the only one that has and it's
funny too because shyla who is listening
to this story she's kind of like
she always kind of like becomes like the
reader she's like poop you didn't tell
me there's gonna be poop in this story
god damn it you know what i mean i was
kind of like yeah yeah i feel seen so
there was that but i just thought but
he's like really it's just it's just a
little bit of poop it's mostly like i
said most of the
extreme stuff in this is like really
really [ __ ] up
like sexual kind of [ __ ]
so but this one does have a little bit
of poop in it so so be warned about that
but the mainly the only thing i want to
say about this
is that
it involves
drug mealing
okay and um
you know drug muelling and or orifices
so
so he tells her this story
and uh she's like pretty disgusted and
horrified uh she's like yeah that's uh
pretty [ __ ] up
which it is
and then he kind of and then they sort
of have a discussion about um about her
and like her line of work and how she
knows like it was actually really
interesting because she's talking about
like different red flags like things
that she looks for like she knows the
dude is gonna be a weirdo or whatever it
is and that's like pretty funny too
um and at this point like angel he's
brought like a backpack with him
and she's kind of like so what you got
in that backpack
and uh so
what he has in the backpack he opens it
and she's kind of relieved because he
sees it's like it's basically like just
a bunch of dildos but like at you know
very like
ever increasing sizes so she's just kind
of like oh okay no big
you know what i mean i thought it was
gonna be like [ __ ] a chainsaw or some
[ __ ] like that um you know but it's fine
so he's like well do you mind i kind of
like i'm into this kind of like dildo
thing and she's kind of like yeah
whatever to like i said it's your money
and they're kind of like talking to each
and like i said as the stories go on
they seem to kind of like try they seem
to be like establishing a rapport with
one another i really liked the the back
and forth between the two characters
because like i said the two characters
are actually uh quite likable
so
as i said i don't want to spoil too much
about all the stories in here but
the stories uh kind of get more and more
[ __ ] up like as the book goes on so
there's kind of stories about
this uh weird self-help
hippie cult thing that does this weird
rebirth uh type situation
uh so there's a story about that
and then there's one about um
a gangbang porn shoot uh if it's
actually pretty entertaining
uh there's one about a uh coat hanger
abortion so you know there's that
uh there's one about a guy who has a
fetish about um
for queening if you know what that is
like if you they want to be like
smothered in a vagina
uh so there's a story about that
uh and there's also
a horrifying story uh that involves a
mannequin
that
uh you really have to like reach to
believe it it's something else so uh so
yeah so there's that
and that's kind of like i kind of feel
like that's maybe the last one or kind
of getting to the last one because it's
the most [ __ ] up thing because it's
like as each story comes along it's like
you know new revelations uh are coming
along and then at the end you kind of
the frame story kind of like comes
around where you figure out what it is
that angel has been getting at like what
it is that he is trying to accomplish
why he told all of these particular
stories in this particular way and
shiloh tells a couple stories as well
so there's that so
if you
are into extreme horror
this is actually one of the best
examples i haven't read a [ __ ] ton of it
but i've read like a fair sampling this
is actually one of the best ones i've
read not not just because not because
it's grosser than the other ones or
anything like that it's gross but it's
not the grossest thing ever but it's not
gross just for the sake of gross like a
lot of the stories have
thematic similarities uh usually like
death rebirth sort of narratives or
things about motherhood um kind of
things like that
you know hence the name of the book
which is womb and actually
this is the title is actually kind of
genius because it's spelled w-o-o-m like
it's room but with a w but then it you
know it means womb also like obviously
like a woman's womb but there's also
something in the story where angel has
um that thing it's not a lisp it's what
is it called rotism or something like
that where you say the r is like w's so
that kind of like factors into the story
as well so that so the title actually
has like multiple meanings and that's
kind of like what a lot of these stories
are it's very very layered and a lot of
the themes
you know repeat themselves across the
stories and like i said as you kind of
go along you see sort of how all these
stories sort of interrelate with one
another and what it is that angel is
getting at why you know what he's hoping
to accomplish by
telling them
uh so there's that but yeah so if you're
into extreme horror this is definitely
an easy easy recommend um it's just it's
really good like i said it's not just
that it's gross and extreme which it is
but
it's also really i don't know i just
found it very like emotionally resonant
i really really liked these two
characters i really liked the way they
related to one another you really
felt for them um like i said even though
they were very damaged even though some
of them had done some kind of appalling
[ __ ] but they were still very human and
you could still kind of like see a lot
of yourself in them and so the character
working this was really really well done
and it's amazing because this isn't a
it's isn't super long it's it's a
novella but the fact that he was able to
put so much
characterization into such a short
kind of time frame was really kind of
amazing so this yeah this was actually
probably one of the most emotionally
resonant sort of extreme horrors that
i've read um so yeah i was really really
into it if you have kindle unlimited uh
you can read it for free now also on the
ebook and probably on the print book too
i would imagine at the end after the you
know main novella of womb there's
actually an excerpt from uh duncan
ralston's 2020 novel the midwives and
that excerpt looked like it was you know
i read it real quick and it just like
seemed really dynamite so i think i
might actually go and read that book as
well and see if that's good because a
lot of people do seem to recommend that
one
but yeah uh this was actually a really
good one like i said if you're not into
extreme horror it's probably gonna be
a bit much um but if you are this is
actually one of the best ones that i've
ever read and i would absolutely
recommend it uh so that will do it for
this tomes of terror i will see you guys
on the next one bye